we have news for make her own a virus vaccine
trial that I am going to call the best possible
news at this stage of the vaccine development
process.
There's been a lot of articles in the last
12, 16, 18 hours saying this is miraculous
news or this is tremendous news or fantastic
less than sort of adding an adjective to it
in that way.
What we can say is knowing the development
process of a vaccine, which we'll talk about
momentarily.
This is essentially as good as it gets at
this stage in the process.
We have a Phase 1 trial which achieved 100
percent immunity.
One hundred percent, meaning protective antibodies,
were the result in every person who received
the doses.
With limited, limited side effects.
This is early in the process.
But at this stage, this is the best possible
result.
Let's look at the details.
The manufacturer of this vaccine is Maduna.
They've already safety tested the vaccine.
This was a Phase 1 trial for efficacy.
Does it work at protecting someone?
And indeed, the first 25 people got either
25 or 100 milligram doses.
All of them had antibody levels at or greater
than the antibody levels of people who get
coronavirus and recover from it.
Naturally, they did.
A second round were eight more people received
doses.
The vaccine again elicited neutralizing antibodies
in all eight of those participants at or above
the levels of the antibodies that someone
who again has had the virus recovers naturally.
You have a certain level of antibodies.
The vaccine elicited that level of antibodies
or greater.
And then those eight people's antibodies then
were able to defeat the virus in a test tube.
So this is very, very big news now in terms
of side effects of that second group of eight
participants.
One person had what's called Grade 3 adverse
events in terms of side effects.
That Grade 3 is pretty serious.
Your daily activity is markedly reduced with
grade 3, they're considered severe side effects.
You usually need some assistance as a result
of the side effects.
You usually need some kind of medical intervention
and sometimes hospitalization.
That was with the higher dose.
They've determined they don't need the higher
dose to generate enough antibodies.
So that is an important thing as well.
What else can we say about this?
You still have to sort out that there's a
lot that still needs to be sorted out.
But this is very, very important in terms
of getting on the way to a vaccine on the
fastest possible schedule.
Now, there's a lot of different important
things that we have to discuss.
There's a general scientific advancement that
this vaccine represents because this is finally
a it's pathet, we'll call it potentially successful
for now until it's widely approved for mass
use.
We'll call it.
It's a potentially successful MRN, a vaccine.
Now, this is a whole new type of vaccine.
Most vaccines that we have right now for other
diseases use either inactivated or weakened
doses of the disease you're trying to protect
against to generate the antibody response.
This type of vaccine from Derna for Corona
virus.
It's an MRN, a vaccine.
It works on a completely different method
by tricking the body into producing specific
viral proteins rather than introducing weakened
versions of the virus into the human body.
There can be much more powerful immunity generated
by this type of vaccine, and it can also be
much more straightforward to produce, which
is a really important part of this.
And so we should talk about production of
the vaccine a little bit.
One of the key things in vaccine production
when it's urgent.
Right now we have an urgent situation.
Getting this vaccine one month earlier could
save a lot of people and it could keep a lot
of people out of the hospital.
So one of the things that comes up when you
have an urgent vaccine development is if you
wait until you have all phases of testing
finished before you start producing it, you're
way behind because it takes a long time to
produce huge numbers of doses.
We are talking here about billions of total
doses that would need to be produced for the
planet.
Of course, you'll likely have more than one
company.
The midterm of vaccine Maidana vaccine is
unlikely to be the vaccine for the whole planet.
But you still need to produce hundreds of
millions of doses.
So what is happening in partnership with the
company?
Lanza Maduna is already moving forward on
establishing manufacturing capacity for this
vaccine and they're going to start making
it in July.
Now, this is very important because the Phase
3 trial of the drug of the vaccine.
Doesn't start until July.
We're about five weeks from that as of right
now.
They are looking to start making this vaccine
while it is still being tested.
And this is the fastest way to eventually
get it to people if it works.
Now it's a risk, right?
You start producing hundreds of millions of
doses.
Maybe Phase 3 doesn't go well and you've wasted
a bunch of money.
That's why in our system, the way we do medicine
financially, this represents a risk.
But they're doing it.
And this is a really, really important thing.
They are going to start production in just
weeks as the vaccine is still being tested
so that hopefully if things go well in the
fall, you would have some significant number
of doses available.
Now, here's one of the difficulties that you've
got to Phase 3 trial starts in July.
It can take about forty forty three forty
five days to generate the full antibody response
to prove that this works.
That's mid-August already.
Then how do you actually prove that it protects
you, right?
You generate the antibodies and you have 40
days, but then you need to make sure that
it actually protects you from the disease.
Well, normally the way you do it in a Phase
3 trial is you follow a huge swath of people
for four months, six months, nine months,
a year.
And then after that time, you would be able
to say, hey, the only five percent of these
people got it or only, you know, compared
to some other portion.
That's how you would figure out that it works.
But the problem is that when these Phase 3
test subjects have the antibodies in mid-August,
only a few percent of the country will have
been infected.
So you could potentially need to observe these
people for a really, really long time before
you can say, hey, they were infected at a
far lower rate than the general population.
They didn't not catch it by chance.
They didn't catch it because of the vaccine.
So what do you do?
Well, there's something called a challenge
trial where you take vaccinated people and
you deliberately expose them to the virus
to see if they get infected.
This is not typically done with vaccines.
And right now, there is no.
In Phase 3 trials.
And right now, there's no challenge trial
planned.
I don't know how else to accelerate Phase
3.
Normally Phase 3 is long.
And it means we just follow these people and
see if they get the virus.
So will there be a challenge trial done so
we can more quickly figure out, does the vaccine
work for large numbers of people?
Hasn't been discussed yet.
We don't know.
So based on all of that, the soonest that
we might have limited availability of this
vaccine, if everything goes perfectly, would
be sometime in the fall.
It would probably be for health care workers
initially.
Then later, you would get to the most vulnerable
populations.
Then significantly later, you would potentially
have the capacity for everybody.
But this is excellent news in so far as at
this stage.
This is the best you can hope for, 100 percent
immunity and limited side effects.
Only with that higher dose, which it turns
out we don't actually need.
Now, what we need to prepare for is the flood
of vaccine disinformation.
That's what I want to talk about next.